[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
France 24 Marta Moya con nosotros en el
estudio Marta bienvenida buena mañana de
martes ya avanzamos semana y vamos a
empezar a hablar de Qatar aunque no
vamos a hablar precisamente del mundial
que se está desarrollando en ese país
sin embargo el país del Golfo Pérsico y
el Mundial fueron escenario el domingo
no de un encuentro simbólico que marca
el lejía en las relaciones entre Turquía
y Egipto Marta silueta con un artículo
de middle si Raúl buenos días Vamos a
hablar de este artículo que titula el
middle Style apretón de manos entre
erdogan y al Sisi
Qatar planeo el encuentro durante meses
y es que en la ceremonia de inauguración
el pasado domingo en doha hubo un
encuentro casi simbólico entre receta y
perdóngan y
adelfatada del Sí sí el presidente de
Egipto Y esto es importante porque desde
2013 desde que se consumó El golpe de
estado en El Cairo El golpe de estado
militar que lideró al Sisi erdogan
llamado al Sí sí dictador y asesino y
las relaciones estaban totalmente
destruidas y no es precisamente
casualidad que el Emir también bit a man
altanic estuviera presente en esta foto
que vemos aquí sonriendo detrás de
erdogan y al Sí sí porque llevaba
gestando el encuentro durante meses
según cita este artículo del midelista
ahí pese a todo hay fuertes tensiones
entre ambos países destaca este artículo
por ejemplo por los intereses en Libia
de ambos países y también por la
presencia de hermanos musulmanes este
grupo islamista que Egipto considera
terrorista No desde ankara consideran
que se apretón de manos tenía el fin de
que Egipto o sea de que Turquía
legitimara al Sí sí como presidente
legítimo de Egipto y desde Egipto
confirmaron que esto significa la retoma
de las relaciones bilaterales porque
Qatar motivó el encuentro algunos
analistas que no tiene fin es más allá
políticos que en la diplomacia deportiva
pero sin embargo catarsis que tiene
intereses sobre todo porque desde 2021
viene estrechando sus relaciones con
Egipto y además Busca un pacto duradero
político en la región sobre todo con el
ojo puesto en Libia cambiamos ahora de
tema Marta Porque la planta nuclear
desaparida en Ucrania vuelve a estar en
todos los titulares de la prensa
internacional por la consecución de los
ataques no y los riesgos de un accidente
en nuclear de momento hasta ahora
descartados porque no hubo digamos
implicaciones dentro de esa planta
nosotros hoy destacamos un fragmento
entonces de la entrevista al director de
la agencia internacional de energía
atómica estamos hablando de Rafael
grossi es una televisión estadounidense
sí nos centramos en el 6 minutes que es
un programa de televisión en Estados
Unidos y destaca una entrevista a Rafael
grossi que es el director del oea que es
este organismo competente en la
cooperación nuclear mundial sobre todo
en la utilización nuclear con fines
pacíficos no grosis se entrevista con
lesliestol que es la presentadora hablan
de zaporilla y Rosi llega a decir que
Rusia tenga una base militar en la
planta nuclear de zaporilla forma parte
de un acuerdo para que no escale el
conflicto y haya un posible accidente
nuclear escuchemos cuando soy consciente
de que una planta de energía nuclear
está bajo ataque mi mente no puede Ni
siquiera es alucinante sin mencionarlo
Qué significa
bien la demanda de protección de la
planta es muy importante no se bombardea
una central nuclear no se asalta una
central nuclear
y si se utiliza una central como base
militar esto es parte del acuerdo que he
propuesto
Sí pero nadie está de acuerdo lo harán
Usted cree yo creo siempre optimista
usted es así además Debo hacerlo
tengo que tirar la toalla
si lo hago se lo imagina no bueno y
seguimos en Ucrania Marta Porque el
Washington post publicó un mapeo los
datos analizados en cuanto al terreno
que ha ganado y ha perdido Rusia desde
el inicio de esta guerra sí Raúl que ha
ganado y perdido Rusia hasta la fecha en
Ucrania se pregunta el Washington post y
esto lo analiza con mapas y datos y
sostiene bueno que la ambiciosa idea del
kremlin de conquistar toda Ucrania en
poco tiempo al final no se materializó Y
que ahora está intentando retener
aquello que obtuvo en los primeros meses
de la guerra no esa guerra rápida al
final no se consumo y dentro de dos días
se cumplen nueve meses de la Guerra el
mapeo está hecho con el institute of War
junto con el Washington post y sostiene
que desde abril Rusia ha sido incapaz de
conseguir más de mil millas cuadradas a
la semana antes de la invasión el 24 de
febrero Rusia ya tenía el 7% del
territorio ucraniano con crimea y
algunas zonas de luwangs idóneask en la
región Oriental del Don Bass a finales
de marzo en ese primer mes de la guerra
Rusia consiguió hacerse con el 22% del
territorio ucraniano y en estos momentos
tiene más o menos el 17,4% del todo el
territorio ucraniano que es el dato la
porción de territorio más baja desde
abril al principio se registraron
grandes avances en el norte y en el sur
luego se replegaron las tropas del
kremlin al Don Bass y ahora están
intentando retener esa zona del este y
del sur aunque han sufrido grandes
pérdidas en harkif o en gerson los
analistas dicen al Washington post que
la estrategia del kremlin ahora pasa por
agotar a esas fuerzas ucranianas con el
fin de disminuir la confianza de los
aliados y una de las claves también
comer si Ucrania logra mantener esa
resistencia en estos en estas semanas
previas al invierno cuando las Fuertes
lluvias y el barro
digamos que dificultan estos movimientos
militares rápidamente en Marta Cómo se
despide la prensa de Pablo Milanés
empezamos con el drama de Cuba que dice
falleció el reconocido trovador cubano
Pablo Milanés como decíamos en el
informativo Miguel Díaz canel ya expresó
sus condolencias destaca que es una voz
inseparable de la banda sonora de
nuestra generación y una de las figuras
más reconocidas de la música cubana su
legado musical 40 discos y un referente
ineludible de la identidad y la cultura
cubana así como de la Revolución El
diario de Cuba dice muere a los 79 años
el trovador cubano Pablo Milanés tras
una larga enfermedad falleció en España
y la corresponsal del Diario de Cuba
dice que en junio cuando se presentó por
última vez en la Habana Ya sonaba esa
representación despedida no Y por último
el mundo de España sostiene que desde su
fallecimiento ya se convierte en una
leyenda del siglo 20 y que la que entró
en la música cubana sentando cátedra en
los años 60 Marta Gracias como siempre
por toda la información mañana con más
revista de prensa Gracias y saluda